I wanna sing a little ditty for my sweet
very short friend Rebecca who is turning
22 tomorrow when quick I won't give you
something anyway never had before
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's an amazing day in wine country when
was the last time we were all together I
just want this to feel like a regular
vacation and somewhere in there I'll
just slide into 50 age is just a number
what would you say your souls age is 18
old enough to drink and bone don't have
my own car yet but I have a bike
I made itineraries so everything we're
gonna do a minute-by-minute on the trip
we have lavender popping corn that's not
enough
Molly ha I did Molly in college but she
went back to her boyfriend sober team of
the girls weekend huh just remember guys
whatever gets said is probably what the
person has always felt and the alcohol
just let it out
this weekend is a mess I can't even plan
a fun birthday trip if you were just to
let go everything will just fall into
place will fall into place do you think
throwing the itineraries out the window
was on the itinerary guess we'll never
know
if we can't get through he came together
and I'm completely lost
[Music]
that's what she said these women I have
known for 20 plus years and yeah
sometimes I want to tell this one to
[ __ ] off you're gonna [ __ ] us that's
what intimacy looks like
this one's good what's it called again
white wine [ __ ] love it
[Music]
you